the people that are on your team the
people that are in your group your
family whoever
you're coaching you might not even know
it but you're coaching
for you as a team leader you're only
going to be able to do it if you can
build great relationships
we've won 11 national championships in
the last 25 years i won two gold medals
at the olympics coaching the u.s
national team
teams are teams no matter what situation
it's a group of people trying to come
together to do something that they can't
do individually
some of the things that you're going to
learn are how to get the best people on
your team that's number one that's key
how to work with them so that you can
raise their level from where they are to
where they hope to be to where you need
them to be it's the same as sports and
it's the same in business and it's the
same in life
how do we build those championship teams
how do we train those incredible players
i go by the old-fashioned catholic
italian way you just make them feel
guilty
you ask them flat out is this the best
you got and invariably they'll say now i
got more all right let's go let's see it
one of the biggest attributes that
resilient leaders have is the ability to
listen
listen more than you talk
because when i got to this country i
didn't speak english
so you're kind of forced to grow up fast
pay attention and learn by watching and
learn by listening
i truly believe there's always pressure
when you're trying to accomplish
something that's meaningful and
rewarding and because of the pressure
and because you perform and you handle
it a certain way you've just grown as a
person
you've just become something more than
what you were before
winning teams understand that the
pursuit of winning never ends
winning a game
is really teaching you how to win at
life
any group can benefit from the
strategies we're going to talk about
and you as a leader can help them reach
their potential
i'm geno auriemma
and this
is masterclass
[Music]
you